es muy confusa se habla hasta el momento
de 13 muertos confirmados más de 60
heridos pero hay otras versiones
manejadas especialmente por la
televisión al yazira a que es qatarí
porque es importante porque qatar ha
jugado un papel muy importante en todo
este proceso en las negociaciones de los
talibanes con eeuu allí tienen su
oficina y han tenido muchísimo acceso en
todos estos últimos días y ellos
aseguran que podrían ser más de 50
muertos informaciones que nos llegan
también desde allí dicen que el caos es
total como decía había muchísimas
personas intentando entrar no solamente
por el lado los británicos sino también
por el lado de los españoles y los
franceses que estaban cerca a ese hotel
barón la confusión es muy grande esta
noche a la gente entiendo que se ha ido
a encerrar en sus casas los que pueden
hacerlo y entonces queda claro de que
esa tranquilidad y esa paz que iban a
traer los talibán supuestamente el que
ellos habían prometido no va a ser tan
así la ciudad termina volviendo a
convertirse en un lugar propicio para la
guerra
absolutamente ahora catalina otra
pregunta que surge en este contexto es
qué significa esto para lo que es el
furor en la evacuación no impar a el
recién estrenado gobierno de los
talibanes
bueno cada país ha tomado sus medidas
los norteamericanos obviamente y los
británicos han hablado el 31 intentando
llevarlo más allí pero hay muchos países
que dan también asegurado que ya para
básicamente van terminando esta
evacuación he hablado con muchas
personas que tenían la última esperanza
de ese abuelo esta noche o mañana
y ya han perdido las esperanzas porque
creen que ya no van a poder entrar al
aeropuerto y han preferido irse hacia
sus casas así que para la evacuación
pues trae la sustración para muchos que
tenían la esperanza de salir y para los
talibán que han condenado ahora este
este atentado casi como si fuera
obviamente como un ente de gobierno
diciendo que van a llevar a la justicia
a aquellos que fueron los responsables
de este atentado pues ahora tienen que
asumir lo que realmente son son el
gobierno de facto de este país tienen
que responder y ellos son los que tienen
que ahora que tener justicia y responder
frente a la población afgana que tiene
muchísimas dudas sobre cómo ellos van a
manejar esto este gobierno y cómo van a
dirigir el país con muchísimas si lo van
a ser igual que lo hicieron ya sé años o
van a venir con una aproximación
diferente